I'm joined today by Tom McShay and Jess
McDonald and Ed Tran hi Danny how you
doing what's up thank you very much for
coming over to San Francisco pre3 and
hanging out with us talk about Nintendo
yeah we're going to talk about Nintendo
productions for E3 uh hands up if you
own a Wii
U are you kidding me what I I thought
you were you play so much in the office
I play so
much I play so much with youu that's the
thing that's funny embarrassing well
whatever so Nintendo historically have
done press conferences like Microsoft
and Sony uh this year much like last
year they are opting to have their own
little sort of Suare off to the side
yeah um Tom are Nintendo relevant in the
grander scheme of video games still yes
next
question they totally like I know what
you mean there's like Nintendo have
always been sitting on the periphery and
sort of doing their own thing but now it
seems like they're really like the
peripher is like over there they're
having a hard time time they're having a
hot but they're still Nintendo they
still got their franchises and to be
honest I think as much as we would all
love to say and keep saying IP new IP
from Nintendo would be so cool I think
at the same time we're all kind of like
yeah I would totally buy a great new
Zelda game and I totally just bought
Mario Kart and I think I think Nintendo
know that I think like they're kind of
like oh yep IP is going to happen but I
wonder if it's ever going to be not just
about the big franchises well everyone
complains about Nintendo's like core
franchises and like not in innovating or
whatever but they always innovate like
within those franchises so like Mario
always does something new each time uh
marott has like more
items car hurle so we we've seen it in
the UK I think the sales for the Wii U
Hardware have gone up 600% week on week
off the back of Mario Kart so do you
think like that's all they need to do
like you you reviewed Mario Kart for I
mean it was it's the same figures when
um super three 3D Mario World yes I
can't remember the name of that game
Super Mario 3D World came out last year
it went up like 600% but it's like it
without the steady flow you're going to
get the the hardcore and then you know
some of the the ancillary fans getting
it but yeah the system still only sold
like 7 million worldwide like it's not
it's not a popular system right now so
okay let's talk about games what games
could they make that would or announce
this year that would get people to hop
back on board on the Wii U on the Wii U
specifically absolutely nothing really I
don't it's it's so hard to turn around
public perception and at this point it's
like oh it's old hardware and it doesn't
do anything that much new or different
and I think that they're they're in a
position where they kind of need to
release new hardware sooner rather than
later which is super sad I mean I feel
like they're they're in a place where if
Mario Cart 8 wasn't going to do it I
don't think anything else is going to do
Super Smash Brothers would be good well
okay so my thing is I am one of those
people who will buy a system if there's
games on it that I want and there can be
cuz Nintendo had that whole thing where
they were like look one game can make a
system and I actually buy into that I
got the 3DS for the Legend of Zelda leag
between worlds because it was phenomenal
it was my favorite game of last year
okay game spots 2013 game I bought it
because it was a gold 3DS with a
Triforce on it but yeah I bought it in
the bundle and that's why I'm not
surprised so many people got the Wii U
with the Mario Cart what did they say um
75% of sales of that title in the UK
were bought within the bundle people
being like yep all right I'll buy a Wii
U now but I kind of agree I think I I
think they might be at the end of the r
you can't say that Mario Kart 8 is not a
fantastic game no probably the second
best console Mario what else can they do
no the way you okay so you already own
one right so Jess you don't yes you
might if there is a game that might your
interest what would that game be and a
new Zelda for instance so I had the my
Nintendo 64 Legend of Zelda Ocarina of
Time is like my baby like if I could
have that kind of experience on a wi U
yeah I probably buy one I think if I was
a Mario Kart 8 person then I would have
bought Mario Kart 8 bundle that would
have been my thing but yeah at the same
time it's kind of dating right now the
way you like next to the Xbox One and
the
PS4 TR if they announce a new Zelda I'll
be quite skeptical cuz I did not enjoy
either of the we zeldas yeah see that's
true I enjoyed uh Link Between Worlds
and I love my I love wi wer not a fan so
what what would you like to see as a fan
and an owner of a of a Wii U Mario
Galaxy 3 really oh man Mario Sunshine 2
space we a bunch of people in the
comments asking for Mario Sunshine But
Sunshine was also very good need that
flood pack back I'm in the exact I don't
ever want another galaxy cuz I think
Galaxy 2 is basically Perfection I gave
it a 10 I don't think you can make a
better game I I defy every developer out
there to make a better 3D platform I
don't think it's possible three words
for the best contendo strategy year of
Waluigi oh no no the messed up thing is
that now we've got all these weird like
rap videos with Luigi and this is much
more hyped than you ever gotten this
actual Year of Luigi H so it looks like
a new Zelda is seems to be like a dead
set like there so much rumor I don't
think the new Zelda will be Wii U
exclusive if it comes to Wii U this is
my this is my crazy prediction so here's
the thing what could I possibly come out
on their next platform I I get really
bummed out when people don't have a
chance to buy an awesome exclusive game
and there's like 7 million Wii U out
there so Wii U Zelda would not sell that
much so I think if it does come out
it'll be like Twilight how it was cross
generational and then it was it was for
wi and for Twilight Princess was shown
at like E3 3 years running or something
wasn't that like they just they kept it
debuted in E3 2005 and then came out a
couple years later yeah or something
like that I don't know but it's like I I
don't I think that if Zola went to the
Wii U alone it would almost be amazing
and then wither and die there without
like people playing it and that makes me
sad so are you on board with the there
might be Hardware this year or I I do I
think I think I think they need to come
out with something next next year or
something they need to start start doing
stuff let's talk about their other
Hardware than 3DS has been doing wildly
successful like ever since the DS light
came out and kind of before that as well
that console that hand has just
dominated the Handel Market um
how what do you think is next for the
3DS is it still fine as a piece of
Hardware itself who owns who owns a p up
F only 3DS see I don't but I always have
the office one yeah yeah so you yeah you
have nintend do you have an n6 this is
what Happ I hey do you play video games
I play so many video games that's the
thing that's crazy the 3DS is weird cuz
it has one awesome game every like three
months but then yeah it kind of see
that's how I I feel about that's how I
feel about the Wii U like as someone who
owns like multiple consoles I'm okay
with having one big Wii U game once in a
while yeah Mario Kart 8 is like just
about the most fun game this year I
don't played anything that much but yeah
then there's be a dry spell and then
yeah so are you are you guys are you
guys still playing with your 3DS's what
have you played most recently that like
the game that we're showing right now
that Kirby game is amazing I love that
it got 100% And I didn't even review it
I just plowed through the game it's
amazing yeah I mean I'm like I'm big on
the major franchises and I'm the same
like I'm happy to just I'm stuck with uh
link between worlds I was playing
because it's my handheld game so I was
playing that between at the same time as
playing games on my PC and um yeah and
that's fine and I'll I'll go through and
I'll play that for a few weeks or
however long it takes and then I'm I'm
kind of okay to put aside a handheld
console for a while and just be like
okay well then and now I'm like okay
cool well I want Pokémon so then I'm
going to I'm going to get on the
bandwagon really late and I've gotten
myself Pokemon and it's like well now
I'm going to play that for a while and
cuz I've got a Vader as well which sort
of does the same thing like let's play
sometimes and then is it not any games I
want for a while so there's like a thing
uh Nintendo's having like a 90 minute
conversation with the Press about a 3DS
game just one one of them there's going
to be two of these things one of them is
for Smash Brothers we already know the
other one's unannounced yeah okay so
there's like a a game that warrants a
90-minute discussion coming out of the
3DS we don't know about what would you
hypothesize that would be well it's it's
obvious to say like I want a new IP like
I want met
Metroid really bad okay that's all I
want is a new Metroid it's been years
and the Ninja Theory one had a
questionable story elements yeah no more
vario suits no more vario suits that you
don't turn on until the man tells
you there's a lot lots of chat about new
Metroid M was asking do you think new
Advanced Wars oh my God be great fire
came out last year that's also
intelligent systems and fire I don't
know if you guys played it yeah is is
amazing I never played one before I
loved it I think the strength of that
yeah maybe more tactics games like that
yeah it's perfect for the handhelds yeah
a good system like just as it is like I
I really I do prefer the 3DS to the beta
like the way it feels it's just like
it's such a solid piece of hardware and
I think that's always going to run in
the 3DS's favor so do you think they're
going to like maybe maybe that's what
happens maybe they just focus more on
the 3DS instead of the the Wii cu the
problem the Wii U has at the moment is
that it's not just F like like exactly
like you said the 3DS is fighting the VA
the Wii U was fighting the PS4 the Xbox
One the two old generation ones and the
PC my whole my whole thing is I want
them to kill both the 3DS and the Wii U
at the same time and then release a new
system this is terrible rele a new
system some people just want to see the
world burn the a portable system that
plugs in your TV so because all because
right now you have all these Nintendo
teams competing against themselves
basically because it's like they're
making a Zelda on the portable and a
Zelda on the console and it's just like
if they could all be in one place and
there's just one Nintendo platform and
it's got every amazing game you could
ever want that sounds pretty good to me
you're crazy I know it's just crazy
enough to work Ed you own a Wii U name a
Wii U game that's coming out this year
that you're excited about Smash Brothers
okay name a second one Smash Brothers
smash the big one for me Bane out of two
okay yes my apolog super gy about ban
out of two high rule Warriors as well
isn't that about that that's an odd one
it sucks cuz it's like high rule oh oh
you interesting though that will sell
them a metric ton of consoles in Japan
really the way he was love the dasty
warrior nuts for it wi was selling as
well as like the PS4 in Japan so it's
doing all right over there yeah is that
team ninja as well Tyro Warriors all
right so te ninja uh Tech no well
they're working with Team ninja te oh
that's what it is yeah okay so it's
sounding a little bit shaky for for uh I
am so excited for Nintendo what they're
going to show because like we don't know
what Retro Studios is making but we know
that whatever they're working is going
to be a masterpiece cuz that's
everything that touches gold that's
right I just want the come back I just
want to see Nintendo cuz when they pull
it out of the bag God they pull it out
of the bag I know and they're like
having a live stream throughout the
entire show and the Treehouse thing is
that right I don't know can you like
reveal they're doing a live presentation
from a tree house Tre outside LA Live oh
no at their booth and they uh reveals
throughout the show oh really during the
actual and everything okay cool why
haven't they made a new Pokemon game for
the Wii U why has there not been Pokemon
snap it's a freaking tablish they're
going to show off the whatever uses the
nearfield communication stuff with the
Wii U which I guess I mean Smash
Brothers is but there's probably be a
game built around that we're going to
get the heartbeat the Vitality sensor I
hope so I don't know what's going on
over that killer Hardware that they've
been waiting for yes okay so it's it's a
sort of a SS side situation exited
because the conversation seems to be
like either you you you stop and rebuild
or we are stuck with like sort of wet
wet blanket releases for the
next I mean it's true but at the same
time when Nintendo releases a game they
release you know Game of the Year from
last year they released Mario Kart 8 so
it's like they're they're they're super
relevant to your first question because
they make the best games what they do
aming games okay well hopefully I don't
think there's anyone on his couch or
anyone watching uh except for boys that
wouldn't want Nintendo to pull something
out of the bag this year so fingers
crossed thanks very much guys for coming
on